hey what's up guys it's Marcus brown we
hear from mkbhd and welcome to a
unusually large unboxing video and I say
that just because this box is on top of
another this box contains a dell
ultrasharp 24:07 WFP B LCD monitor so
does that box but for this video we're
going to be unboxing one of them just
because it wouldn't make sense to unbox
both and I'm actually not narrating this
with my USB microphone so pardon the
imperfections but this is the first time
I'm doing such a big unboxing so I'm
sorry if the audio is a little bit
quieter when I move away from the camera
but without any further ado here we go
also at the end of this video I will
show you the setup of both the monitors
next to each other so you can actually
see that there are two and you can see
right off the bat there is a lot of
bubble wrap and air packages and peanuts
and stuff so I'll fast forward the video
while I take these out so one second
all right so you can see if the stand
itself came separate from the panel in
this particular package I'm not sort of
how the other one will come but I'm
going to go ahead and show you real
quick how to attach the panel to the
stand so you can get it working and
sliding up and down and adjusting it the
way you need it to be right so here you
can see this is the stand itself you uh
once you first get it you're going to
have to attach that base to the swivel
point so this can swivel and that takes
four screws so if it doesn't come
attached you're going to need to do that
I already have the monitor right here
this is one of them I'm going to take
the one I just unbox that I just showed
you and actually connect it and show you
guys how easy it is and give you an
overview of the monitor so hopefully
this isn't too difficult all you have to
do is take that back portion of a
monitor and line it up with those four
line up things so see if I can do this
without obstructing the camera okay so
it was actually pretty easy even though
I moved a little bit you guys saw
hopefully you got to see without me
getting in the way that that's pretty
easy to connect all right now we've had
the monitor laid down on its face so you
guys can actually look at all the ports
and also before entity I just want to
apologize that this video is so short
I'm just getting this video out before I
leave so I'll just go ahead and show you
now this is the power cable the standard
power plug this right here is the
speaker power so there are built-in
speakers in the monitor this is the dual
link DVI and standard VGA cables then
you have s-video cable this yellow cable
right here I'll go ahead and zoom in a
little bit so you can see more these are
s-video cables and these are your three
component cables your RGB cables over
here all the way on the right-hand side
you'll see a powered USB port and two
USB out ports so that's a two port USB
hub right here and the other two are
actually on the other side of the
monitors so you guys have a four port
USB hub when you plug this monitor into
your computer via that one USB port so
that's an overview of the back of the
monitor and quick unboxing of this ultra
short monitor and now go ahead and show
you guys just what it looks like when
you have both the monitors set up if you
happen to get - alright so this is what
the two monitors actually look like
together when you go ahead and put them
on your desk as you can see these are
both like I said 24-inch 1928 cross by
1200 down and these are both Matt
monitors and they have quite a thin
bezel if you can see over here I'll go
ahead and zoom in you can see this is a
matte bezel and it's actually quite thin
so both the monitors are at the same
height and at the same angle so you can
see if you want to angle them they'll
take up a little bit less space on your
desk
etc so these are going to be part of the
custom bill that I am working on pardon
the macro focus here but these are part
of a custom bill that I am working on
now I don't really know if people want
to see a set up tour I've had a couple
of people ask I like to watch set up
tours personally but I don't know if I
would do one unless a lot of you guys
asked for one so anyway this has been
mkbhd and thanks for watching the
unboxing of the dell ultrasharp 24:07
WFP be the specs will be in the
description the description of this
video down below and until next time
mkbhd signing out
you